award-winning actress amy adams says she
feels a personal connection to her
latest role in the new movie hillbilly
elegy
adams plays beverly vance opposite
co-star glenn close
in the film which is based on jd vance's
best-selling memoir
it has been one of the most popular
movies on netflix in recent weeks
but surprisingly critics have tossed
almost nothing but hatchets creating
what director ron howard told us
is quote the biggest differential he's
ever had between critical consensus
and audience approval ratings think
about that we talked with amy adams
about this weird gap and also
why the movie nonetheless resonates with
viewers
i always feel like i've yet to make a
film that everybody agrees on
and so i keep trying but i actually
don't think it's a negative
sign i think i think actually you know a
movie should not be
uh bland it should inspire a strong
feeling that was something like growing
up when someone
i'd rather as much as i want to be liked
indifference was the worst thing because
i would i would chase the indifference
constantly to try to
force an opinion one way or the other
amy adams says she didn't have to force
anything to get into the mind of jd
vance's real-life
mother beverly i just had a down
you know month though she played a woman
struggling with addiction in appalachia
where vance once wrote
poverty is the family tradition you
can't just take him because he's not
yours
really might as well be i want to go
adams says
she felt a connection
you want to go and live with her
what about it is familiar from your
background
well i just think sort of this idea that
we pass on the traumas of our ancestors
you know and
and and how do we stop that from
happening that's something that
um weighs heavy on me as a mother sort
of how do i keep
things that i suffered through uh from
occurring with my daughter how do i
break that cycle
are you thinking about addiction in
particular or
poverty or some other kind of hardship
for me the thing that i battle with
is a lot of self-doubt and i question
myself and finding my voice it took me a
really long time to
um find my self-worth and my
my agency and that's something i don't
want to pass on to my daughter the
feeling of being comfortable in your
surroundings you mean
yeah comfortable in my surroundings
comfortable in my skin
comfortable with an opinion comfortable
with people not liking you
and even after two decades on screen not
to mention a half dozen oscar
nominations
and a pair of golden globes adams saw
something of herself
in young jd's store jd's on does this
transformation from ohio and kentucky to
to yale and feels a little bit out of
water
were you able to relate to that uh going
from small town colorado to
absolutely i didn't always feel like i
belonged and definitely coming to
hollywood and sort of getting the
opportunities that i've had i've
definitely fallen into the imposter
complex from time to time
probably even still during the election
year of 2016
jd vance's insights into appalachia
turned him into what the washington post
called the trump whisperer
or the rust belt anger translator and
while this year is defined not by a
reckoning with
rural decline but racial injustice adam
sees the very same sparks
of conversation i've heard from people
unsolicited
that spoke to either the addiction or
the trauma
it's one of the first movies where a
crew member has come up to me and talked
about their experience so
it definitely gets people feeling that's
a good sign what do you hope
the typical viewer takes away from the
movie i hope
you know a that they can take away
empathy for people that they might
not understand and might not agree with
at times
but i also hope that some people feel
seen
yeah she's an amazing actor she she is
yes
i'm glad people i thought i really
enjoyed the movie i read the book
and then looked at the movie and ron
howard has put together such a great
cast
you know i i realize that the reviews
may not be so great but i love all their
um
attitudes about it yeah you know i
thought ron howard said it very well
yeah well it's very peculiar that some
of these publications that so hailed the
book
are now coming after the movie with
criticism and it's sort of a sad thing
that happens in this country
where it's like if we're focusing on
this group and its problems we can't
also acknowledge that this other group
also has problems and like it's not a
contest of suffering
both problems matter yeah so but so far
so good
in terms of the viewers what the viewers
think yeah that's all that matters
ron howard has done a lot of movies have
to say this is the biggest gap
is what matters i look forward to every
amy adams performance no matter what
me too